everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend I want
you to meet four key he's a spool yes
yeah I know four key is the most
important toy to Bonnie right now we all
have to make sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was paper soup salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we gotta get pork
permit
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on bow bow hi there my name is
Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boys
what are you doing here no time to
explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody you always come in
to the rescue Bonnie needs 40 woody who
needs a kid's room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Bonnie we have to
find the totally do but what would would
he do jump out of a moving vehicle let's
go hey you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks if you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home for you
on my way whatever with Finity and
beyond
kids lose their toys every day I was
made to help a child I don't remember it
being this hard
ready somebody's whispering in your ear
[Music]
you